the British library has a copy of every
book ever published in the UK or at
least it should have if you're in the UK
and you publish a book magazine or
newspaper then by law you have to send a
copy here a lot of countries around the
world have similar laws and similar
libraries the rules what must be sent
here were pretty simple to understand
until the end of the 20th century when
the web came along and suddenly books
and Publishing weren't quite as easy to
Define in the print world we collect
everything so anything you can imagine
whether that is an NHS information
leaflet local magazine or the most
expensive Journal that you can imagine
all those beautiful art books that cost
thousands of pounds those kids magazines
that you see on the shelves in Tesco's
with the plastic toys on WE collect all
of those it's everything down in the
basement here there's obviously a huge
amount of storage but it's not enough
and here in London land is expensive and
construction is difficult so while there
are millions of books stored here
they're only the ones that are the most
requested the rest of them are with the
robots up north the library collection
in total is around 170 million items at
the vast majority of that is is legal
deposit often Publishers know legal
deposit and will send them in more of a
challenge can be very small Publishers
or people who don't necessarily think of
themselves as Publishers so we put a lot
of effort into reaching out to authors
creators who self-publish all those
kinds of organizations to say the work
is really important to be saved and
preserved in total there are more than
700 kilometers of shelves and most of
them are stacked up here in one of the
Colossal low oxygen storage buildings in
Boston spa in Yorkshire I was not
allowed to attach a camera to one of
these robots they are far too important
the library is using up those shelves
about eight kilometers per year so
they've just started construction on
their next storage building which should
be good for a few decades lots of the
stuff that gets sent out free tends to
be ephemera and it will be lost over
time a great example is a recent
exhibition up in the National Library of
Scotland all about the information that
was provided at the very beginning of
the AIDS epidemic that material if you
go out to somebody on the street and you
ask them should we be collecting this no
of course we shouldn't but we're able to
learn so much from that we wouldn't have
that exhibition if we hadn't collected
that free material that came through
people's letterboxes if someone in
London wants a lesser used book from
these Stacks they need to give 48 hours
notice it'll get picked out by these
robots they go up to 50 kilometers an
hour if you can hear wind rustling on my
mic it's because they shove air out the
way as they travel through the stacks
and they automatically store items that
are used more often close to the front
the books are then put on a truck South
to arrive in the reading rooms a couple
of working days later more than a
thousand items go back and forth each
day but publication means something
different now not only are there books
that are only being published as digital
files but there's the web legal deposit
has expanded to include publishing on
the web as long as we can identify that
as being within the UK so if someone's
creating a blog or creating their own
website we will try to collect that the
UK web archive has actually become one
of the largest parts of the collection
billions of files about one and a half
petabytes of data a digital newspaper
for example is very different from a
print newspaper so we have to make sure
we collect both because the editorial
intent of both is very different and in
addition to that there are no emerging
formats you can read books which change
as you move the iPad around you can read
books that change depending on your
location how do we capture that today to
make it available for researchers in 10
years 50 years time you know how often
you have to change the operating system
on your phone so it's quite difficult to
keep up with those changes I've used the
British library for research a lot of
times the books you request can't be
borrowed and taken away they have to
stay with the researcher at a desk
inside one of the reading rooms returned
after they're done this is a library of
Last Resort if you want to get a library
card here there will be a short
interview about your research and why
you can't just pull the books or
material you want from your local or
University Library the importance of
legal deposit not being selective and
being everything is we can't decide
today what's going to be important in 50
years time we want everything because we
don't know what will be important I
cannot overstate just how useful it is
to be able to track down things that
never made it online or to research out
of print forgotten books where there are
no other copies available or to scan
through every issue of an obscure local
newspaper to track down one reference
this is the raw text of history as it
happened and someone has to keep it
preserved for the future
how's that for timing
I wish I'd done that deliberately